the need for a new chapter right this is
a faint disquiet
no doubt we're all
familiar with this
fire
in the belly a kind of faint
disquiet the beginning of a dis
ease
that
won't let go once it takes a hold of us
and it starts whispering in our ear that
a change is coming that a change is
necessary and sometimes we don't want
to answer that call because
it's just not safe to go there or you
don't feel ready or you can't be
bothered or you lack the courage
but
a problem to be solved
becomes a problem that solves you
once you heed the call like you know
the cave you fear holds the treasure you
seek you know
the medicine doesn't taste good going
down but that's the point everything you
want is at the edge of your comfort zone
everything you want is on the other side
of fear and this
leap of faith
requires a kind of little death because
heeding the call to adventure means
leaving the familiar world behind and
there is a kind of mourning
like the scene in the matrix when neo
sticks his finger into the mirror after
taking the red pill and starts to melt
into the mirror alluding to alice
through the looking glass and what eric
davis calls the mystic psychotic
collapse when baseline reality and that
familiar world dissolves and no new
reality has yet emerged in its
pixelating wake there's a moment of
ontological uncertainty who am i
where am i
what do i do next and so we're terrified
of that nakedness and that vulnerability
but nonetheless the need for that new
chapter
will force itself upon you whether or
not you answer the call or like in the
movie
walter milly there you go just every
time it's daydreaming having in this
office all that until when he goes on on
the helicopter hundred percent he's that
song singing and he's all inspired to
get on that plane and jump off that
helicopter into water-infested sharks
and it's like freeing it's like getting
out of the bubble of comfort zone that
you have and spraying that journey that
you always have like camino santiago
climbing everest hundred percent
whatever the amazon swimming naked in
the amazon like matthew mcconaughey
is freeing yourself of society and
embracing yourself in that journey well
100 i mean that film is is a fantastic
high-res rendering of the hero's journey
i love i love the secret life of walter
mitty i think ben stiller was an
exceptional
director and actor in executing a vision
of the call to adventure of the need for
a new chapter one that beckons like the
archetypal character played by
sean o'connell what's his name sean penn
sean penn in the film is is is this is
the is the voice that begins that
disquiet it is the whisper of a thrill
that tells walter mitty that something
needs to change and walter mitty of
course begins the film as a misfit he's
out of place he's socially awkward he
has no confidence he can't stand his
ground and so the world is surrounded by
bullies it's an anxious place and he is
paralyzed to act but he breaks through
to the tunes of david bowie right to the
most wonderful of anthems he takes the
leap he flies to iceland a landscape
as epic as the transformation that
ensued you know a landscape as epic as
his heart needed something can measure
it to his need to his capacity to wonder
and wander you know to die to himself
and everything about the film is an
execution of the
the heroism the courage but also the
redemption and the cathartic
transformation and transmutation that
comes when we answer the call and
embrace the new chapter you know like
matthew mcconaughey anecdotally writing
in his novel about that time when he
dreamed that he was floating naked in
the amazon river being eaten by piranha
and anacondas and he woke up the next
day and flew down there and threw
himself into the amazon river naked
floating downstream and he found what he
was looking for we all
need to answer that disquiet that
invites us to a new adventure we don't
have the choice not to right what
happens if we don't answer it
it will answer us bro
we will pay the price you know
yeah you don't embrace it nothing will
come like it's a magnet if you bring out
those journeys those things will come to
you the people that want that type of
experience will come to you if you're a
person that buys a lamborghini and
you're talking about you don't want
people come for your money and all that
you're go that's what it's going to
bring that that
exactly is a magnet your creative and
linguistic choices will govern your fate
man you choose and you become and and
and and here's where it's really kind of
a cautionary tale and i just read this
yesterday but i thought it was so
beautiful it basically said that if you
dot if you do not transform your pain
you will most certainly transmit
it if you do not transform your pain you
will most certainly transmit it
and so this is where
well i don't think you have a choice if
you don't answer the question if you
don't heed the call if you don't
embrace that next chapter if you don't
allow that problem to be solved to
become a problem that solves you if you
do not transform your pain
you will undoubtedly transmit it and
that's what you don't want bro you don't
want to make more toxicity in the world
you don't want to make more pain in the
world you don't want more pain in your
wake man you want to be a force of
redemption or even it can eat you that's
exactly depression like 100 seen with
even with the famous actors like robert
williams that's right and that that
depressions have ate him and completely
and we have lost
potential great people because they they
yeah famous life great experience but
they maybe didn't
took that leap of faith that everybody
should take out i mean i think at some
point no matter how far you've come
there always comes a a necessity to take
another chapter right and and and and if
you keep holding on for whatever reason
into anything
um you'll see devils tearing your life
away but if you let go
you'll see that the devils are really
angels freeing you and freeing your soul
this is from the film jacob's ladder and
so to that end folks um
answer the call
if you feel the next chapter coming
embrace it
um
because again if you do not transform
your pain you will most certainly
transmit